non
21h43 ici à paris place à votre journal
de l'afrique sur france 24 ce n'est les
bienvenus la victoire fragile de kyle
hyde et en tunisie son projet de
nouvelle constitution est en passe
d'être adopté selon des sondages un
grand oui mais avec une grande
abstention texte confère au président
des pouvoirs élargis notre envoyé
spécial karim yahiaoui nous attend à
tunis
10 morts à butembo dans le nord kivu en
rdc trois casques bleus sept
manifestants
deuxième jour de rassemblements contre
la monusco la mission de l'onu accusés
d'impuissance face aux violences dans
l'est du pays la sécurité justement ni
la tournée africaine de manuel macron
est avocat moon avant le bénin et la
guinée-bissau visite alors que l'
influence française sur continent est
remise en cause face à la russie
notamment
les résultats officiels se font attendre
en tunisie mais une nouvelle
constitution se profile avec un
président omnipotent selon des sondages
le oui l'a emporté avec plus de 90% des
suffrages au référendum constitutionnel
voulu par cai ça aide le texte renforce
les pouvoirs du chef d'état appelle un
tunisien sur trois s'est déplacé pour
voter à tunis on retrouve l'envoyé
spécial de france 24 karim yahiaoui
bonjour karim el vous avez suivi ce
scrutin ces derniers jours pour pour
france 24 ce référendum finalement
n'aura pas été qu'une simple réponse par
oui ou non c'est l'essence 1 d'un
référendum à cette nouvelle constitution
c'est vrai l'ensemble des tunisiens
qu'on a pu rencontrer depuis que nous
sommes arrivés en tunisie avec mohamed
farhat et android iard et bien on ne
nous ont pas forcément parler de ce
référendum ils sont parfois aller voter
pour d'autres raisons pour bouleverser
un échiquier politique qu'ils rendent
responsables de tous les échecs
accumulés ces dix dernières années
depuis la révolution de 2011 beaucoup ne
veulent plus entendre parler d'ennahda
le parti islamiste qui était au coeur de
toutes les coalitions ces dernières
années ceux qui sont allés voter même si
ne sont pas du tout majoritaire dans le
pays veulent un changement de système
parce qu'il considère et bien que les
fruits de la révolution eh bien ils
n'ont pas pu du tout en profiter depuis
depuis dix ans c'est vrai que c'était
aussi une campagne particulière il n'y a
quasiment pas eu de campagne d'ailleurs
très peu d' affiches et ça s'est
finalement transformé en référendum
contre ou pour qui ça aide plus qu'un
référendum pour cette constitution qui
pourtant bouleverse totalement la vie
politique tunisienne
cette victoire elle est fragile 1 je le
disais l'abstention et record - d'un
tunisien je le rappelle - d'un tunisien
sur trois qui s'est déplacé pour voter
ce qui pose la question de la légitimité
évidemment
évidemment cette légitimité fragile aux
yeux de l'opposition tunisienne qui à
peine les premières estimations apparu
pointé du doigt une absence de
légitimité pour qui ça aide étant donné
l'abstention extrêmement importante ce
qui n'est pas forcément rassurant pour
l'avenir c'est que l'espace politique
est complètement fragmenté puisqu'il n'y
a pas eu cette capacité du côté de
l'opposition à s'unir pour tenter de
contrecarrer le projet du président
tunisien il ya eu çà et là quelques
manifestations quelques hommes
politiques qui ont tenté de faire
entendre leur voix dans cette campagne
kiné qui n'en était pas une le pays
semble plutôt fracturé entre ceux qui
ont choisi de ne pas se pas se déplacer
pour aller voter et ceux qui accordent
leur confiance en cas isced une
confiance qui ensemble un petit peu à un
vote de la dernière chance parce qu'il
espère enfin que leur quotidien pourra
changer le pays est en grande difficulté
économique nous nous sommes rendus dans
certaines régions délaissées notamment
la ville de kaffrine où une chômage fait
des ravages et là bas on espère que
c'est une nouvelle ère qui débute mais
en tout cas l'espace politique tunisien
et plus morcelé que jamais et la
réconciliation ne sera pas forcément
chose aisée karim
oui avec mohamed farhat et android r les
envoyés spéciaux de france 24 en tunisie
merci parce qu'elle craignait une dérive
autoritaire l'opposition avait appelé
les électeurs à boycotter le scrutin
avec ce texte le président jouit de
prérogatives élargies et n'a de compte à
rendre à personne
une rupture avec la constitution de 2014
issu du printemps arabe nina masson
sophie samaille
le 26 janvier 2014 trois ans après le
début des printemps arabes
les députés tunisiens adopte une
nouvelle constitution le premier article
reprend mot pour mot la précédente
constitution daté de 1959 la tunisie est
un état libre indépendant et souverain
l'islam et sa religion l'arabe sa langue
et la république son régime le texte ali
laïcité islam et pour la première fois
dans un pays arabe la constitution
garantit la liberté de croyance et de
conscience et le libre exercice des
cultes la charia elle n'est pas
mentionnée comme source de droit huit
ans plus tard c'est un tout autre projet
que propose le président kaïs ayed son
objectif offrir un pouvoir inattaquable
au chef de l'état qui dispose d'une
immunité pendant toute la durée de son
mandat la nouvelle constitution réduit
aussi considérablement le rôle et le
pouvoir du parlement et prévoit la mise
en place d'une seconde chambre
l'assemblée nationale des régions créer
sur le modèle des sénat français ou
américains enfin l'un des points les
plus débattus concerne la place de
l'islam l'article 5 du projet
présidentiel pose que la tunisie fait
partie de l'oumma islamique au sein d'un
système démocratique
seul l'état devra veiller à garantir les
objectifs de l'islam une disposition
critiquée par les défenseurs d'une
séparation nette entre la religion et
l'état
un référendum constitutionnel qui
s'inscrit dans la lignée de ce coup de
force d'il ya un an kate sayid s'était
arrogé les pleins pouvoirs cet ancien
professeur de droit constitutionnel est
lui largement en 2019 son portrait
avant même son arrivée au pouvoir qu'à y
ça y est c'est toujours affranchi de
toute appartenance politique je suis le
candidat de cale parti je suis l
indépendant je le resterai
conservateur assumé il se pose alors en
défenseur de la constitution élu
président en octobre 2019 il doit
composer avec hainard d'arriver en tête
des législatives dans un parlement
fragmenté ce parti islamo conservateur
prend l'ascendant grâce à des alliances
avec d'autres partis
mais les divisions au sein du parlement
finisse par paralyser le pays le 25
juillet dernier coup de tonnerre
kaïs ayed limoges le premier ministre et
gèle les travaux du parlement le début
d'un état d'exception qui dure depuis
maintenant un an en février dernier cas
et ça y est tu supprimes le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
remplacé par un conseil provisoire dont
il nomme lui même la majorité des
membres un mois plus tard il dissout le
parlement des législatives sont
annoncées pour décembre autre décision
de caïx ça y est celle de nommer le chef
de l'autorité électorale l'instance
supérieure indépendante pour les
élections le chef de l'état qui gouverne
désormais par décret détient la quasi
totalité des pouvoirs le 30 juin dernier
il rend public son projet de nouvelle
constitution qui renforce un peu plus le
pouvoir du président et ses liens
directs avec le peuple on en vient la
tournée politique d' emmanuel macron en
afrique le président français totem
rhône où il a rencontré son homologue
paul biya il se rendra ensuite au bénin
et en guinée-bissau à yaoundé guerre en
ukraine oblige il a évoqué les
conséquences géopolitiques d'un tel
conflit alors que l'affluence françaises
reculent sur le continent face à la con
il est revenu sur la stratégie du
kremlin sur sol africain préoccupante
selon lui
cette présence russe hybride qui passe
par la désinformation par les milices
para du coude de nouvelles formes que
j'ai du mal à qualifier de coopération
mais donc de complicité avec des
pouvoirs politiques affaiblie
voire totalement illégitime quand ce
sont des militaires est une
préoccupation et je pense c'est d'abord
une préoccupation pour le continent
africain
trente cinq ans après la mort de thomas
sankara blaise compaore demande pardon à
sa famille au peuple burkinabè lui qui a
été condamné par contumace en avril
dernier à la perpétuité pour son rôle
dans le meurtre de son prédécesseur il
est arrivé au pouvoir en 1987 à la
faveur d'un coup d'état qui a coûté la
vie à sankara alors à la tête du pays
l'ancien chef d'état vite actuellement
en côte d'ivoire
terminus pour un projet ferroviaire
vieux de 15 ans celui entre le niger le
bénin et le groupe bolloré et trois
partis se sont mis d'accord pour y
mettre fin les explications de harold
gérard à niamey
en accord
deux ans c'est ce qu'a annoncé vendredi
le ministre béninois d'état chargée du
développement
le niger et le bénin avait lancé dès
2008 un appel d'offres pour la
construction mais également la gestion
d'un réseau ferroviaire qui relierait
les deux pays mais le premier litige
survient en 2013 lorsque ce marché est
confiée au groupe de vincent bolloré
plutôt qu'à l'entreprise béninoise
pétrole 1 qui avait remporté quelques
années plus tôt cet appel d'offres petro
la porte plainte plusieurs fois et finit
par remporter un procès en 2015 mais
entre-temps le groupe bolloré avait déjà
réalisé les travaux à hauteur de 140 km
de lignes ferrées entre la ville
nigérienne de dosso et la capitale
niamey le groupe bolloré réclamait dès
lors des réparations d'une compensation
financière pour le travail déjà effectué
un accord a donc été trouvé mais
malheureusement pour les nigériens et
bien toujours pas de train à l'horizon à
lamballe beaucoup de choses on parle
beaucoup de choses parce que
et le fait de
la ville mais elle a eu la vie
maintenant c'est un peu
val à vitesse grand v s'ils avaient un
train qui arrive pour amener des
marchandises ou la lenteur avec les
camions et la masse est une idée parce
que les consommateurs on attend el
materi qui doit arriver pour certain
nombre de choses avec le trap tête c'est
une semaine par mois le niger pays
enclavé entre cet autre nation dépend
énormément de ses voisins pour acheminer
tous types de marchandises l'absence de
trains ne risque pas d'améliorer cette
situation est depuis quelques années
l'insécurité grandissante aux frontières
de plusieurs de ces pays ne fait que
ralentir l'économie nigérienne ils
prennent de l'ampleur et deviennent de
plus en plus violents les rassemblements
anti monusco dans l'est de la rdc tue
cinq manifestants à goma lundi ce fait
ce mardi à à butembo et trois casques
bleus à chaque fois plusieurs blessés
également présente depuis plus de 20 ans
la mission de l'onu n'est plus la
bienvenue correspondance de clément bono
les manifestations anti monusco s'étend
désormais à plusieurs villes de l'est de
la rdc ce mardi des heurts ont éclaté à
butembo la troisième ville du nord kivu
les manifestants ont été dispersés par
les forces de l'ordre selon la monusco
des assaillants ont violemment arraché
des armes à des éléments de la police
nationale congolaise est tirée à bout
portant sur les forces de maintien de la
paix plusieurs morts sont à déplorer
côté casques bleus mais aussi côté
manifestants avec également plusieurs
blessés à goma la tension était
également vive ce mardi au deuxième jour
de manifestations contre la monusco des
centaines de manifestants étaient
toujours dans la rue notamment autour de
la base logistique de la force de l'onu
ils réclament toujours le départ de la
force onusienne qu'ils accusent d'être
passive face aux massacres de civils par
les groupes armés l'armée congolaise a
été déployé toute la journée pour
maintenir l'ordre lundi les
manifestations avaient rapidement
dégénéré et virer au saccage et au
pillage des locaux de la monusco
une mission forte de plus de 14 mille
hommes présente sur le terrain je vous
le disais depuis plus de 20 ans une
mission qui n'est plus la bienvenue en
retour sur cet historique avec florent
robin
novembre
1999 les premières troupes de l'onu sont
déployés dans le nord kivu pour
maintenir la paix et faire respecter
l'accord qui a mis fin à la deuxième
guerre du congo
un an plus tard la monuc voit son mandat
élargi elle est désormais en charge de
la protection des civils du personnel
humanitaire et des défenseurs des droits
de l'homme le pays est instable il est
notamment confronté à l'arrivée massive
de milices venus du rwanda voisin
associé à des groupes armés congolais
opposés au gouvernement central elle
pillent les richesses nationales les
casques bleus deviennent vite leurs
cibles privilégiées
en 2013 face à la recrudescence des
attaques le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies créé une brigade
d'intervention spéciale
la monusco comme on l'appelle désormais
devient alors la plus importante
opération de maintien de la paix de
l'onu dans le monde et surtout la plus
chère en 2016 2017 son budget annuel
atteint presque 1 milliard 200 millions
d'euros elle mobilise près de 17000
militaires appuyés par des observateurs
et officier d'état major des policiers
mais aussi des membres d'unités
spéciales fin 2021 le mandat de la
monusco est reconduit pour 12 mois
supplémentaires jusqu'en décembre 2022
mais avec des effectifs réduits à savoir
3500 militaires en moins sa mission
principale
consolider sa présence en ituri au
nord-kivu et au sud-kivu
ces trois provinces congolaises où
persistent des conflits armés ouvert
merci d'être fidèle au journal de
l'afrique le reste de l'actu
internationale c'est dans quelques
minutes et c'est avec avec les rebonds
mission jour peau dans 45 minutes reste
avec nous
[Musique]
la guerre est aux portes de l'europe et
nous rappellent les heures sombres de
notre histoire il ya des bombardements
incessants depuis ce matin france24
maintient la lumière sur les évènements
sucre miens c'est eu des gens sans
raison c'est de la folie
nos équipes en plateau et sur le terrain
continue de vous alerter
ces quartiers
restez informés rester éclairé et
liberté égalité actualité